so there's different obstacles for
different things
i want to reach mark
he's got me now i'm sort of hanging on
here now i've got to get mass right i've
got mass
oh i've not projected him anymore
knowing i'll get mass
well now i'm not projecting anymore
decide one or the other suburbs
punch him and that was a suburbia
but when doing taboo you learn mass
you learn that you learn stability
if you do that in a carter it becomes
knee
sun oh i need a breath right
so that's not a carter the carter is a
free-flowing move
so so what i'm trying to get you to do
and you're doing stages
is if you can couple up the first one i
don't like this sort of thing
but if you can couple up just before the
end of that it
flowed into another one
this would be a card
the problem is the teachers who
demonstrate that there's a lot of them
they don't actually end the move
it becomes like
it becomes a very shortened version of
what you're supposed to be doing
what i was showing you what i'm hoping
what you'll absorb and take away
and in one day get it is the expansion
these are all individuals these are all
individuals
see individual
this is keeping my energy expansion
but it's doing the fall
okay it's really difficult of course it
is
nearly 50 years i'm just discovering
this
if i can give it to you earlier what a
bonus it is for
me to have the joy of watching you get
here
and you thinking oh i wish i'd read this
earlier